[Musique]
les élus du département se sont réunis
en séance plénière ce mercredi 26 juin
dans l'hémicycle du palais de la source
à l'ordre du jour la recentralisation du
rsa le plan pauvreté et l'étude agri
pays 2030
le président cyrille melchior s'est
réjoui concernant l'avancée de la
recentralisation du rsa dont la date de
mise en oeuvre a été validé par le
gouvernement
elle entrera en oeuvre au 1er janvier
2020 quand on veut recentraliser le rsa
c'est en fait pour pouvoir se dégager
des marges de manoeuvre pour mieux
accompagner aussi les familles en
difficulté et accompagner les
bénéficiaires du rsa mais pas seulement
les bénéficiaires du rsa
toutes les familles en difficulté je
pense aussi aux jeunes je pense aux
agriculteurs par exemple way donc on
doit accompagner sans cesse notre public
est donc là nous avons un très bon
dossier qui est l'accompagnement
on a demandé vice-président jean-marie
virapoullé a travaillé avec moi pour
qu'on puisse présenter un dossier qui
consiste à prévoir pour les personnes
qui le souhaitent rentrer dans
l'association soit par la formation soit
par la mobilité professionnelle ou par
la présente la création d'activités de
l'entreprise que ces personnes ne perd
pas le droit tout d'un coup droit le
bled à logement droit verra ça voyez
autre sujet à l'ordre du jour
l'agriculture réunionnaise la
collectivité départementale a décidé de
porter une réflexion sur le modèle
agricole de demain
en se basant sur des fondamentaux c'est
pour lancer véritablement le projet
maintenant que deux modèles qu'on
souhaite avoir pour l'agriculture
réunionnaise
un modèle qui sera basée toujours sur le
réseau familial puisque nous voulons
rester dans un contexte sur lequel notre
agriculteur puisse continuer à
s'épanouir qu'ils puissent surtout
obtenir un revenu et faire vivre sa
famille donc nous avons bien évidemment
calais nos orientations sur ce principe
lui trouver aussi du foncier
c'est la clé de voûte de l'agriculture
sia pas de foncier on peut pas produire
on peut pas faire des projets de
développement d'exploitation et bien sûr
continuer à appuyer dans l'agriculture
sur nos petiots nos principales filières
la filière canne dans son ensemble par
l'est également
des filières fientes des filières fruits
et légumes et puis aujourd'hui il ya de
nouvelles de nouveaux secteurs qui se
présente à nous comme l'horticulture
comme le miel comme les papables tous
ses activités agricoles viendront je
dirais consolider le modèle agricole que
nous avons aujourd'hui c'est un modèle à
l'école rénovée que nous allons
finaliser d'ici le mois d'octobre
prochain
une séance plénière qui marquait le
départ à la retraite de pierre bayle
directeur général des services du
département l'ancien secrétaire général
de la préfecture de la réunion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]